also sie haben gerade gesehen und jetzt
ist er uns zugeschaltet der
geschäftsführer des textilunternehmens
trigema wolfgang grupp zusammen mit
seiner frau schönen guten abend den
beiden einen schönen guten abend braucht
man einen schönen abend
ich bin der herr kauf aber es macht die
hitze ich hab auch ne feminine seite na
gut
gehen wir direkt in medias res was
halten sie von 3g am arbeitsplatz und
das ist sicherung von den experten
richtig gedacht aber es ist dann sehr
schwierig natürlich durch zuführung weil
es gibt natürlich auch bei uns sowohl
wir über 80 prozent geimpft sind in der
firma gibt es natürlich ein paar die
sich haben nicht impfen lassen und die
jetzt natürlich sozusagen streng
angegangen werden und die sich gewisse
dinge gefallen lassen müssen und da gibt
es einige überredungskunst und das habe
ich versucht und meine frau auch aber
die leute sind natürlich nicht ganz
einverstanden mit vielem aber sie werden
sich in der sache fügen und werden das
auf sich nehmen hair group hier ist denn
home office bei ihnen möglich eigentlich
eine textil produktion geht ja
größtenteils eigentlich nicht von
zuhause oder
home office ist bei uns nicht angesagt
wie ich brauche konstant auch meine
verwaltungsmitarbeiter die müssen da
sein weil wir sehr schnell entscheiden
müssen und das ist unsere stärke dass
wir im prinzip sehr schnell entscheiden
und auch die produktion sehr schnell den
wünschen anpassen die auf uns zukommen
und da ist ein home office ist nicht
möglich und deshalb ist auch bei uns im
moment niemanden homo frau gruppe er man
hat gerade gesagt ihre mitarbeiter sind
nicht gerade glücklich über diese
situation warum ich was deren vorbehalte
was sagen sie ihn
ist natürlich immer die leute
informieren sich heute sehr stark über
das internet und wir haben ja heute
schon begonnen mit den testungen
offiziell ist es ja erst mittwoch wir
haben uns gedacht bei firma trigema
beginnen wir schon einmal mit dem
warmlaufen wir mussten ja auch unsere
abteilungsleiter an schulen damit sie
also auch die richtigen tests
durchführen und die vorbehalte gegen
impfungen sind nach wie vor sehr stark
aber wir haben
ich würde gerne mal nachfragt was sind
das für vorbehalte was sagen ihre
mitarbeiter und wie viel prozent sind
überhaupt gekämpft
und sind also knapp 80 geben und wir
haben also eine sehr gute impfquote
diejenigen die sich nicht impfen lassen
haben einfach angst vor den
nebenwirkungen und ich glaube das muss
heute ganz stark noch einmal publiziert
werden dass die impfung wirklich sicher
ist dass wir einfach mit der impfung nur
die auch die ungeschützt sind schützen
können und das versuchen wir jetzt schon
seit einigen tagen wir haben jetzt
allerdings schon ein erfolg dass ich
sage durch diese androhung von 3g dass
also die ungeimpften auch gewusst haben
dass sie sich ab heute beziehungsweise
ab mittwoch dann wirklich den testen
lassen müssen sind zumindest schon ein
kleiner erfolg hier leute heute haben
sich schon zu impfungen angemeldet also
die leute wollen oder unsere mitarbeiter
wollen auch sage ich sich dem druck im
täglichen druck sich testen lassen zu
müssen nicht immer aussetzen wir haben
da heute ja auch schon öfters mal drüber
gesprochen über die impfpflicht ob sie
kommen soll oder nicht was ist denn ihre
persönliche meinung dazu
also gut okay ich bin gebürtige
österreicherin also das liegt ja schon
etwas nach ich glaube wir können den
harten kern der jetzt sich nicht impfen
lassen möchte nur durch eine impfpflicht
dazu verpflichten
neben den schutz der ungeschützten zu
bewerkstelligen also ich glaube eine
impfpflicht ist jetzt sowieso schon
durch die hintertür und wird auch
hoffentlich offizielle kommen wir haben
ja darüber gesprochen das sind nicht
immer alle einer meinung selbst in den
familien nicht was ist ihre meinung herr
grupp impfpflicht ja oder nein in
deutschland ja ich bin schon lange für
die pflicht weil mich fragt ja auch
keiner ob ich irgendwie eine
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung
einhalten will oder nicht da werde ich
genau so muss ich mich anpassen im sinne
der allgemeinheit und so ähnlich sehe
ich dass ich sag mal nicht nur für sich
selber sondern auch zum schutz der
anderen die um mich herum sind und
deshalb halte ich wenn es nicht anders
möglich ist eine impfpflicht
unausweichlich denn die leute sind ja
normal mit anderen impfungen auf gewohnt
und ich höre immer mehr dass man also
auch nichts dagegen hat wenn man ein
wenn man es sich impfen lassen muss aber
es gibt ein paar die sich dagegen
sträuben aber die werden wir auch noch
überzeugt dann noch eine letzte frage
zum schluss mit der bitte um eine
relativ kurze antwort aber welche
maßnahmen würden sie sich dann
zusätzlich noch von der politik wünschen
sie haben jetzt gerade von der
impfpflicht gesprochen aber gibt es da
noch andere dinge die sie fordern
also generell bin ich der meinung dass
wir jetzt klar schiff machen müssen wir
müssen sagen wie es in der nächsten zeit
eher wird und vor allem sollten wir
wissen dass im prinzip auch die
geschäfte offen bleiben wenn wir uns an
das halten was die politik vor was
schenken sie ihrer frau zu weihnachten
hair group
ich habe sie akustisch nicht schenken
sie ihrer frau zu weihnachten
meine frau kriegt immer alles was sie
möchte nämlich ein großes pussy vor mir
und wir haben uns schon immer gesagt wir
schenken uns an weihnachten nichts weil
wir uns im prinzip immer noch nie
streiten im jahr und das ist das größte
geschenk das ist allerdings ein sehr
großes geschenk dass krieg nicht jeder
ganz herzlichen dank ihnen beiden